كيف تستقر في حياتك
كقائد للبطولة ، أردنا دائمًا أن
نكون هنا والآن بعد أن أصبح لدينا
حزمة تنافسية للغاية كما تعلمون ، نحن سعداء جدًا بحدوث
ذلك والآن علينا
فقط مواكبة ذلك ، أعني أنه لا
يزال  موسم طويل نحن لسنا حتى في منتصف الطريق
وبالطبع الفجوة في الوقت الحالي
تبدو
لطيفة على الورق ، لكنها أيضًا
اختفت بسهولة ،
وأتذكر التحدث إلى نيكو روزبرغ
حول عام فوزه بالبطولة
وقال
إنه كان فريقًا عائليًا واعيًا
مثل  كل قرار يشمل الحياة
بأن هذا كان الهدف هو أن كيف يكون الأمر
بالنسبة لك ،
لا أعتقد أنني أحب ذلك ، أنا
بارد جدًا ، ليس الأمر كما لو
أنني بحاجة إلى إعطائه 110 لأن ذلك بالنسبة
لي لا يعمل
أنا فقط  أعرف ما يجب أن أفعله خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع للسباق ،
لست بحاجة إلى المزيد ، دعنا نقول
التركيز بجانبه لأكون دائمًا في
المنطقة لأن هذا لا يعمل بالنسبة لي
ما تتوقعه من سيلفرستون
لأنه سباق
مرسيدس  وسيطر لويس على ذلك
كثيرًا
صحيح في السنوات الأخيرة على الرغم من أننا فزنا بالسباق الأخير
هناك ، لذلك هذا صحيح ،
يجب أن تكون إيجابيًا أيضًا ولكننا
نعلم أنهم سيكونون
أقوياء جدًا هناك ، فهم يجلبون
ترقيات لذلك لن يكون الأمر سهلاً ولكن  أنا
واثق من أنه يمكننا القيام بعمل
جيد هنا ،
ومن الواضح أنك حظيت بتجربة رائعة
مع عدد كبير من
المعجبين في النمسا مرتديًا اللون البرتقالي الخاص بك ولكن
بالعودة إلى سيلفرستون
حيث نتوقع السعة الكاملة كيف
سيكون ذلك جيدًا  إنه لأمر رائع
أن أرى ذلك أعني
أننا فقدنا حقًا ذلك العام الماضي عندما
وصلنا إلى سيلفرستون ، فأنت تعلم أن هناك
مسارًا رائعًا للقيادة ولكن عدم
وجود المعجبين هناك كان
مختلفًا تمامًا لذلك
أنا فقط أتطلع للعودة إلى
هناك  ارفع أحد
مقطوعاتي المفضلة ثم شاهد جميع
المعجبين الرسميين المتحمسين وأنت تعلم أن
هناك الكثير من التاريخ
بشكل عام حول سيلفرستون لذلك
أعتقد حقًا أنها ستكون
عطلة نهاية أسبوع رائعة نظرًا لأن هذا الدعم الحزبي الجماهيري
إن جي لويس سوف يمنحك
القليل من التفوق النفسي الذي تعتقد
أنه يجب
أن تهزم لويس على أرضه هذا العام ،
أعتقد أنه سيكون على ما يرام ، أعني أن
إيطاليا تغلبت على إنجلترا
ويجب أن يكون ويمبلي بخير ، شكرًا لتذكيري
بما تتوقعه من
السباق الهولندي عندما يحدث أخيرًا في
وقت لاحق من هذا العام ، لن
يكون هناك ما يكفي من القمصان البرتقالية في هولندا ، وسأحرص على وجود ما يكفي من القمصان البرتقالية في
هولندا ،
وأعني
بصراحة أنني لم أفكر
مطلقًا عندما بدأت في الفورمولا واحد للسباق في
هولندا.  مرة أخرى ، أعني أن السباق الأخير كان
في عام 1985 ، لذا
حتى تكون قادرًا على معرفة أنهم نجحوا في ذلك
مرة أخرى ، فهذا أمر مذهل وهو
مسار مدرسي قديم حقًا بالطبع قاموا
بإجراء بعض التغييرات ولكن المسار نفسه
لا يزال
مجزيًا للغاية إذا تمكنت من تجاوزه  في اللفة
ولكن بالطبع معاقبة للغاية إذا
ارتكبت خطأ ، لذا بالتأكيد أتطلع
إلى قيادة المسار أولاً وقبل كل شيء ولكن بعد
ذلك بالطبع كل
ما تعرفه لرؤية جميع المشجعين على
المدرجات الكبرى وفي الكثبان الرملية ونأمل أن
يكون هناك الكثير من اللون البرتقالي حولها  نعم
، سيكون الأمر رائعًا في أي نقطة
ستسمح
لنفسك بالاعتقاد بأن هذه هي
السنة التي تفوز فيها بالبطولة ،
أفضل عدم التفكير في هذا النوع
من الأشياء ،
لا يمكنك التفكير في هذه الأشياء
لأنه يجب عليك التركيز على ما
لديك  للقيام
به وبالطبع آمل أن يكون هناك
فجوة كبيرة في أبو ظبي ولكن
نعم لا تعرف أن الكثير من الأشياء يمكن أن
تتغير خلال عطلة نهاية أسبوع واحدة لسباق واحد
بالفعل ، لذلك
علينا فقط أن نأخذها خطوة بخطوة في
كل سباق